que peut-on faire sans le bac c'est la
question que se posent les 15 % de
jeunes qui ont échoué cette année à
l'examen
la plupart bons vont tout simplement
redoublé c'est qu'ils ignorent souvent
c'est qu'il est possible de faire des
études dans l'enseignement supérieur et
même de réussir sans diplôme
siame saveurs et laurent beaufils
accompagnée de son père cette jeune
fille de 18 ans cherche une solution
pour son avenir
profondément déçu par son échec au
baccalauréat
amélie est reçu par un conseiller
d'orientation j'ai passé un bac
hôtellerie d'accord et j'ai loupé en
point et vous l'avez raté une fois
simplement on a droit en échec ce n'est
pas catastrophique
si vous leur passé ce sera fait voilà
c'est un passage une finalité en soi
mais vous serez peut-être bloqué amont
une autre dans l'évolution de carrière
ce n'est pas le baccalauréat
les trois quarts des lycéens qui ont
échoué au bac choisissent le
redoublement
amélie le refuse elle cherche avec son
père d'autres options bien ouais je me
dis qu'on peut faire un bts
professionnalisant même si on n'a pas eu
le bac
oui mais c'est des écoles privées donc
pouvoir les prix
bon ben écoute on situe à tous les
renseignements on va continuer sans le
baccalauréat
l'inscription en bts est possible en
école privée reste la formation en
alternance ou même certaines études de
droit à l'université on peut survivre et
bien sans baccalauréat et peut-être
aussi se réorienter sur des métiers
qu'on n'avait pas choisi parce qu'on a
tendance à avancer dans les études à ce
ton bac d'abord alors qu'il ya un tas de
métiers je pense aux métiers de
l'artisanat l'artisanat d'art des choses
qu'on salue métiers du sport la recette
du succès ne passe pas forcément par le
bac
la preuve malgré ses deux échecs à
l'examen gaëtan a réussi dans la
pâtisserie
pour moi ce que je pense maintenant le
bac c'est une ouverture pour d'autres
études sinon ça vaut pas grand chose
avec un peu zappé après une cinquième
une bonne dizaine d'années après je suis
devenu chef d'entreprise dont je pense
que le bac n'est pas ses soeurs ici la
persévérance a remplacé le diplôme mais
l'alternance est réservé aux lycéens qui
souhaitent travailler rapidement pour
les autres malheureux candidats au bac
2010 il est encore possible de reprendre
le chemin de l'école
à condition d'avoir un projet